i love it i think i find you interesting
and when they approach to have you on
the show
i've been a fan for a while because i
think your journey there's some
similarities between you and i
what i find interesting is i'm sure when
you did the you you dropped out of
college to do
you know the mtv shows i don't know if
you thought you'd be to this level
right like this wwe superstar and then
you have that
ultimate kind of persona on there where
you call yourself the miz
and at first i was like yeah whatever
that's fun but where's this gonna go
and this is where it led to and i'm sure
for you you know we have a mutual friend
theo vaughn
theo is one of my best friends and
you know theo's one of the top comics in
the world now i don't know if you keep
up with theo vaughn but literally when
the top oh i keep up with theo yeah he
is
fantastic and incredible so
i'll give you a back story on theo uh
for anyone that doesn't know who theo
vaughn
is uh he was first on road rules about
20 years ago
uh which was a reality show that was
very wildly popular
and i remember going on a challenge
which is a sister show
of road rules in real world they come
together for the challenge it's a huge
show even right now on mtv
uh so we went on that show together and
i remember theo telling me
i was like i want to be a wwe superstar
he's like well i want to be a stand-up
comic
and i remember him going to the front of
the bus when we were on the way to go to
the challenge there's 30 of us on there
not many people know each other but i
knew theo
from earlier and he got up on the
microphone and started telling his jokes
and everyone was crying laughing
and this is him just beginning yeah this
is his first start like this is his
first routine that he had
and it was it was god i can't remember
the jokes but it was like
remember when like uh like the the the
telephone companies had like dialed down
the middle yeah
and like you know 1 800 a dial down the
middle and it's like
he would make up these entire jokes
about the telephone companies like
that's how old
how long ago that was and so
now cut to maybe 15 years later
i'm at the improv and i'm taking uh
my wife to go out on a night on the town
and we go to the improv i'm there
have no idea who is who's playing who's
going to be you know performing that
night
and the main event is theo vaughn
and i i had no idea and i was like oh my
god like
i know this guy like this is incredible
and then
when i watched him perform i i was i was
almost
it was almost an emotion came over me of
how proud i was
yes of him of where he came from when he
told me
i want to be a stand-up comic to the
level
of comedy that he was displaying like he
was like by far the best performer there
that night
and i was like this guy is ready for the
main stage so afterwards i texted him
and said oh my god i'm in the crowd
how amazing that was in that was in so
we set up
and he said i have a stand-up special
coming up on netflix
and then i watched the stand-up special
i was like this guy my god
he had a dream he had a desire he
figured out all the tools that he needed
that was necessary
to become the artist he is and now there
he is
at the top of his game one of the best
comedians out there
in my mind my favorite and it just goes
to show that hard work determination and
a goal
when you have something and you said i'm
going to go for it that's what i did
i said i'm going to gain all these tools
that i need to become a wwe superstar
and that's where my mind is that's where
i'm set up and i'm going to do it
yeah and it just goes to show even if
you're on a reality show you still
can do it because even though a lot of
times people look at reality shows and
go
whatever your no talent hacks yeah just
live your life on tv but
you know people some people have proved
them wrong yeah you i mean you and theo
are the the example of that
when i text theo you're coming on the
show he said i love
i love that dude he saved my life one
time from some house
he was absolutely loved the miz and i
you know with theo
he doesn't he he's gonna hate me even
talking about this but [ __ ] it
he um you know he doesn't talk a lot
about his mtv days
he doesn't like to address his stuff
like that because he's in such a diff
different lane now and he's he's known
for that
he doesn't like to ever look back in the
past did you feel like it was hard for
you to shed that label with the mtv and
the reality show stuff like that like
did people think i was there like there
was a time
in my career so the reason where he is
saying
and i think this i think i understand
where theo is coming from
so back in the day when we were on
reality shows there was only a couple
a couple available like real world road
rules uh
big brother uh survivor there was a
handful of them now
it's a dime a dozen hell instagram's a
reality show if you want
tic tocs is a reality show if you want
but back then
back when we were on we we couldn't get
into a room to audition
for anything yeah they looked at us as
no talent hacks and that that we were
just
on a reality show and that's all we
could do is just
be on a reality show and we couldn't do
anything else and we would never amount
to anything
so when you're putting the passion and
trust me i have never said
a bad thing about what is mtv or buda
murray because i've always been very
grateful
sure for being on the real world for
being on the challenges because
it set me up and it gave me a whole
different mind frame
that if i believe in myself that i
could do something i could pursue
something different than what
was supposed to happen and in where i
was from parma
ohio you're supposed to go to college
after college you go back to parma ohio
after you go to parma ohio you
you get a family you get a job and
that's what you do for the rest of your
life
but being on the real world it set me
off and said i know i could
i could be a wwe superstar even though
they're six
seven full of muscle and
and and charisma and and they're larger
than life
i could do this if i set my mind to it
and so where i think i have been able to
say you know what
screw it i don't care what anyone else
thinks of
you know if i'm on a reality show or not
like there's paths
and nowadays i say do it all
yeah like my agent will ask me like what
do you want and i go i want it all
and he goes what do you mean by that i
want reality i want hosting
i want movies i want wwe i want
it all everything give it to me because
i want to show
that i have the talent in whatever i'm
doing
to be able to succeed at it and so give
it to me
and so now my my my agent has done a
tremendous job
in getting me all these different things
and all these different opportunities
like i get to do miz and misses which is
our reality show about my family
inside the life of like what it is like
to be a wwe superstar
and be a dad of two beautiful daughters
and be a husband to a wife who's also in
wwe
and we made a comedy show like literally
i look at our show
it's a reality show it's based on us
absolutely but i look at it like the
office
i look at it like curb your enthusiasm
like seinfeld and people are like oh my
god you're looking at it like the
greatest show ever yeah
yeah i am yeah and i'm proud of it yeah
well one show that i think people will
watch with their families and go
and laugh and enjoy and you know with
wwe i'm doing the best work i think i've
ever done
in wwe because now i have a mindset
that i can do anything i can do it all
and i'm not gonna sit there and say
i'm not gonna choose this lane like they
asked me to do the
challenge all-stars and i was i won't do
a challenge again because i don't want
i don't want the drama but i wouldn't
mind
hosting it or doing a guest host spot
because
i always want to pay tribute to where i
started yeah and who gave me my
opportunity and that is mtv and buda
murray
and the real world good for you well i
when i always think about you like even
from those
you know earlier days i think everything
you've always done
has just been so authentic and it seems
like
you know when you trans transition from
mtv to wwe
like it didn't it like i never saw it as
like this weird thing like what the hell
is he doing he's this guy from
you know real world or whatever why is
he trying to do wrestling i always
thought it was like
oh [ __ ] yeah he's doing it and it just
it just seems like you've always just
been
authentic and true to like like like
you've been saying like yeah if i want
to do it
i'm going to do it you know so i think
it's been cool to like
see not apologizing for it either yeah
just doing exactly what i want to do
because i believe what i'm doing could
make a difference in
in something like as stupid as a reality
show is
like it's a reality show about something
but guess what there's meaning there's
issues that we tackle
that i think a lot of families are
dealing with that sometimes especially
in a time like we are right now with all
the drama in the world
i think it's some some i think it goes
to show that we need things on tv
that literally you can just set your set
all the pressures that you're having
with your day
sit down with your family and just laugh
and relax and enjoy
and i think we need that in television
well yeah
look just looking at the result of
everything you do like it's like this
guy
really does believe it like he really
does
feel it and that's yeah and i don't know
i just think that's like cool because
like you could easily not
you know like yeah most people wouldn't
take wouldn't be able to transition from
the mtv
uh reality world and be able to jump to
something that they really want
yeah to do to that point too i think ms
is like i'm sure when you told
your family and friends you're gonna go
into the wwe
and i'm sure fans that were you know
around then were like dude what are you
doing that's stupid you know because
i think for a lot of people like you
switching lanes for them doesn't
doesn't make sense like no those guys
have been wrestling since they were kids
you know so i think a lot of them like
you you always say stay in your lane
it's like well no i like a bunch of
lanes man
you can that's your that's your you're
pushing that agenda on me i don't want
to be in that lane i won't be in this
lane this lane in this lane
everyone's always going to tell you you
can't do something and the reason they
sometimes tell you that
is because they can't do it they can't
see themselves doing it
doesn't mean that you have to listen to
that person as a matter of fact
i listen to those people i hear them and
i use it as
fuel for my fire to say hey i want to
prove them wrong but not only do i want
to prove them wrong i want to make sure
that they know that
when i succeed at it if they have a
dream
they can do it as well yeah and so
and maybe they'll turn that negativity
into positivity and that's where
i kind of i stem everything in my life
from is like i try to
generate positive and people are like
but you're a villain on tv it's like
yeah
but i'm a villain who when the good guy
beats me everyone celebrates and
everybody is happy
and it always has it coming i know you
know
in wwe the villain's gonna have it
coming sometime or another someone's
gonna give it to him
and you're gonna have a reaction a
celebration like
the coolest thing you can have as a wwe
superstar is when you have a title
i had i just had the wwe championship
the most coveted title
in all of wwe i had it for eight days
i went up against bobby lashley that's
my guy
right now is on fire
how big of a freak is bobby lashley oh
my god you know i used to train with
bobby
i used to train with bobby and you know
he has legit like credential wrestling
background in the military
and when we would wrestle i never saw
him get taken down
once ever ever upon muscle
like he has a six-pack and then he has a
six-pack on top of that six-pack that's
how
jacked and big this guy is but not only
that tiny head
let's say he's a very hard worker very
dedicated to the craft
and it's taken he's never held the wwe
championship
even though we everyone's always known
he's going to get it some time or
another
and then he went away from wwe and then
he came back
and he set the world on fire and when i
lost the wwe championship
even though we were two bad guys people
were
celebrating bobby lashley's reign as a
wwe championship for the first time i
remember
going backstage in gorilla and everyone
applauding
and literally saying congratulations you
deserve it and to me
i was proud because i was like wow like
we did that in a matter of eight days
yep we built this this program where
people were really looking at it and
then
here's the repercussions everyone's like
oh you only had it for eight days
oh you only have yeah anytime you have
the wwe championship
if it's for eight days uh if it's for a
day
if it's for a minute if it's for a
second you are
the wwe champion and you will always
have that
yeah so eight days as long as you
do what is necessary for the company and
wwe to succeed
to build another superstar which we did
we
built bobby lashley into this huge
monster
and now he has a huge match against drew
mcintyre
who by the way through the out the
entire pandemic with
no fans only virtual fans which wwe has
done a tremendous job of
has been able to carry the wwe
championship for most of that
and has done a terrific so these two
titans are going to go head-to-head at
wrestlemania
and i was able to be a part of that
story
to build these two characters to where
they are going
in a prime time main event wrestlemania
caliber match
so i'm proud of the work that i've done
and i hope
that they are proud of the work that
they're done because i can't wait to see
the match at wrestlemania yeah i think
it's interesting the
out of all the major sports leagues the
only ones who really did it right and
had success during the pandemic was the
wwe
and the ufc you know yeah i mean wwe has
done
a tremendous job in making sure that
each and every week
you know the fans have something live to
watch
when baseball was gone nba was gone
football was gone all sports were gone
we were still there
trying to entertain an audience because
in in the most
critical time that they need it and i
felt safe doing it
yep respect respect man
well miss we've i've won john's show for
a while man like i said i'm a big fan
you're you're a
motivational guy it's uh it's hard to
get me motivated man not a lot of people
motivate me i love
i love your story man i really do you
make me want to stand up you guys
i really appreciate you guys taking the
time to have me on your show
yeah um it's an honor and a privilege so
keep up the good work
and uh please if you talk to theo before
i do tell him i said hello and then we
talk great things about him because
he truly is uh one of those people that
i don't think sometimes he gets enough
credit yeah he's a special guest
one of the best stand-ups out there
agree agree man well appreciate you miz
good luck uh april 10th and 11th good
luck brother
no need for luck when you're this good
baby
all right brother have a good one man
how about that when i get off stage at
the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son